FRANCOIS AJENSTAT: At Tableau,
our mission is simple.
It's to help people see and
understand their data.
So the Google Cloud Platform
really helps a company like
Tableau analyze billions of
records of data at internet
scale with simple point
and click operations.
All you need to focus on is
putting your data on the
Google Cloud Platform, and
Google takes care of the rest.
So you can focus on the core
aspects of your business
rather than managing all
that infrastructure.
MOMCHIL KYURKCHIEV: So we are
Leanplum, and we're building a
platform to optimize the mission
critical metrics of
your mobile app.
We're a young company,
less than a year old.
And so for us, building
a minimum viable
product is very important.
So we start with something
small, and then we upgrade it.
I think App Engine is designed
exactly for this use case.
I'm always surprised by how
fast mobile has managed to
penetrate in our lives
and the amount of
data that we collect.
FRANCOIS AJENSTAT: We can
connect with Tableau to Google
BigQuery as well as
Google Analytics.
And Google BigQuery, as part of
the Google Cloud Platform,
really helps us analyze millions
and billions of
records in a way that was
never possible before.
ANDREW FIST: BigQuery allowed us
to analyze large data sets
in very little amount of time,
and that's great when you're
building an Analytics product.
And it's also great when you're
a startup, and you
don't have the ability to
reserve tons and tons of
instances, because you
get them all, on
demand, within seconds.
FRANCOIS AJENSTAT: So if you
think about the traditional
environment, companies have to
install lots of servers, lots
of software on premise.
They'll build Hadoop stacks with
thousands and thousands
of servers that are really,
really hard to manage.
Now, the beauty of the Google
Cloud Platform is that it
makes all of that irrelevant.
So slow moving, painful,
expensive, complicated, to
fast, nimble, and responsive,
is really that difference
between the old way and the
Google Cloud Platform way.